hello each day we hear bad news coming
out of Iran Iran's government violating
people's right in fundamental pay just
yesterday two young men one at age of 19
another at age of 35 were executed and
this is very sad Iran's government bring
any excuse and forced them to confess
again is their self increasing so then
later under this condition they execute
them the government try to terrorize
people up even to not come today slit I
think this is responsibility of
international community raised kudelka
root ism told Iran's government I think
this is a white time that United Nations
Secretary appoint a special invoice on
Iran's efforts yo man wife's condition
is getting worse and bulls and Iran and
I am requesting everybody especially for
Economic Forum's members could take
responsibility to raise their criticism
regarding human rights issue thank you